In one year, the smartest AI jumped from
96 to 136 IQ on the Mensa Norway test.
In other words, in one year, AI went
from the intelligence of an average
person to nearly the IQ of a genius.
This has AI scientists terrified. And
the godfather of AI and Nobel laurate,
Jeffrey Hinton,
>> is in the process of tidying up his
affairs. He believes that we maybe, I
guess by now, have four years left. But
why exactly are scientists so worried
about AI getting smarter? Recently, AI
has begun improving itself, and they
believe that this process may soon end
in a runaway intelligence explosion that
destroys the world.
>> Extinction risk from godlike AI is not
just possible, but imminent. So to
understand how close we really are to
that outcome, we're breaking down
Liupold Ashen Brener's famous report
situational awareness which is
circulating among top US government
officials. AI progress won't stop at
human level. Hundreds of millions of
AGIs could automate AI research
compressing a decade of algorithmic
progress or five orders of magnitude
into one year. We would rapidly go from
human level to vastly superhuman AI
systems. The power and the peril of
super intelligence would be dramatic.
Most people think the atomic bomb is the
most gameboard flipping invention in the
history of war. But arguably the
hydrogen bomb was just as important.
One atomic bomb could wipe out a city,
but one hydrogen bomb could wipe out a
country.
a single bomb with more explosive power
than all of the bombs dropped in the
entirety of World War II combined.
That's the scale of the difference we're
talking about between AGI or artificial
general intelligence and super
intelligence. But what does this
difference mean in real life? And how
dangerous for humans could this really
be? Imagine this. A civilization of AI
systems, billions of them, each vastly
more intelligent than many human,
capable of novel, creative, and
incomprehensibly complex behavior. Their
power wouldn't stop at machine learning.
Super intelligence would ignite
explosive progress across every field.
Robotics, biotech, weapon systems,
material science. I mean, what took
humans decades, they solve in days.
An industrial explosion would follow,
then a military one. It would offer
god-like power both to create and to
destroy. And once it begins, we will be
living through the most volatile moment
in the history of our species. So, how
close are we to this future? Well, Ashen
Brener lays out four critical steps to
get to super intelligence. The first is
getting to AGI, which we previously
covered. The next steps are all about
using AI to automate AI research itself.
And here's the problem. Former Google
CEO Eric Schmidt warned, "That's a
dangerous point." And this recursive
self-improvement isn't just a theory.
It's already happening. Microsoft CEO
Sat Nadella says AI development is being
optimized by OpenAI's 01 model and has
entered a recursive phase. We're using
AI to build AI tools to build better AI.
A scientist at Google DeepMind reveals
>> what we did was actually to build a
system that through reinforcement
learning itself figured out what
algorithm was best at reinforcement
learning and incredibly actually
outperformed all of the human
reinforcement learning algorithms that
we'd come up with ourselves over many
many years in the past. I think the
actual majority of code that's written
written at entropic is you know at this
at this point uh written by one of the
quad models but first things first we
have to reach AGI and then we can worry
about all the other steps right the
problem is AGI is much closer than we
think the three major heads of AI labs
all think this is going to happen in the
next 2 to 5 years and everyone's
timelines for AGI are shrinking even
famous AI skeptics like Yan Makun
>> it's not centuries. It may not be
decades, but it's several years.
>> Besides, automating AI research isn't
actually as hard as it seems. To get
there, you don't need the AI to become
genius level in every field. Imagine
trying to create an expert biologist AI
that can research new cures for
diseases. You don't start by training it
on biology. You only need to automate AI
research so that the AI itself can think
faster and become smarter. Then once it
is much smarter, it could easily and
quickly learn advanced biology or any
topic for that matter. And we've already
seen leaps like this happen before.
Alpha Zero was able to without being
taught anything about humans, no
education of like the history of human
chess playing within 3 hours of
experimentation was stronger than any
human or computer in history. So imagine
your life's work 10 hours a day for 30,
40 years being the greatest human in the
world at it. And then something can come
in and within 3 hours of experimentation
be much stronger than them. And imagine
that's going to be in everything
>> after the move C4
has resigned
>> right now. This is happening at an
insane pace in the field of robotics. A
year ago, humanoid robots weren't
advanced enough to even walk smoothly.
But a tactic called reinforcement
learning changed everything. Robots can
now learn not just to walk, but to do
side flips, kip ups, and even kung fu
completely on their own. Boston Dynamics
Atlas learn to run and break dance by
simulating running. Think of
implications. One hour of wall clock
compute time gives a robot 10 years of
training experience. That's how Neo in
the Matrix was able to learn kung fu in
the blink of an eye. I know kung fu. Do
you realize just how suddenly our little
chatpots might go from blinking cursors
to very real things? Some people assume
that we'll see robots in the real world
slowly getting better over years or
decades. But if they can learn 10,000
times faster via simulation, they could
blow our expectations out of the water.
So there's a very real chance we'll see
humanoid robots casually walking around
pretty much everywhere in the next 5
years. And there are many more examples
of these fast takeoffs using
reinforcement learning. Minecraft,
Shogi, Go, Chess, etc. But even if we
don't get a fast takeoff, we're in for a
wild ride. Remember, Ashenbrer argues
that we don't need to automate robotics
research to get to super intelligence.
We just need to automate AI research.
The job of an AI researcher is fairly
straightforward. Read machine learning
literature and come up with new
questions or ideas, implement
experiments to test those ideas, and
interpret the results and repeat. This
all seems squarely in the domain where
simple extrapolations of current AI
capabilities could easily take us to or
beyond the levels of the best humans by
the end of 2027. That's why AI being
able to research better algorithms on
its own is such a big deal. Models get
smarter and cheaper to run and train as
you invest more computing power into
training them and can find more
efficient algorithms to run them. In
fact, LLMs are getting 9 to 900 times
cheaper per year.
Sit with that for a second. That's like
if a $50,000 Tesla dropped to just $50
and ran better. And that's not just
about saving money. Algorithmic
breakthroughs are essentially getting
more computing power for free. When we
have more compute, we can use it to make
the models smarter and cheaper, and the
cycle repeats.
But once we do reach AGI, we won't just
have one of its kind. Ashen Brener and
other researchers used basic compute
inference forecasts to show that once we
train the first AGI, we'll easily have
the computing power to run millions of
copies, perhaps 100 million. A single
H100, one of today's top AI chips, has
about the same raw computing power as a
human brain. And we're on track to have
100 million H100 equivalents worldwide
in just a few years. That's potentially
100 million AI workers right there. But
the thing is, our automated AI
researchers may soon be able to run at a
much faster than human speed. The first
algorithmic innovation the automated AI
researchers work on is getting a 10
times or 100 times speed up. Gemini 1.5
Flash is 10 times faster than the
originally released GPT4 merely a year
later while providing similar
performance. If that's the algorithmic
speed up a few hundred human researchers
can find in a year, the automated AI
researchers will be able to find similar
wins very quickly.
That is expect 100 million automated
researchers each working at 100 times
human speed not long after we begin to
be able to automate AI research.
At that pace, you'd move as slow as a
plant to them. They'll each be able to
do a year's worth of work in just a few
days.
This is why Jeffrey Hinton is terrified.
Once these artificial intelligences get
smarter than we are, they will take
control. They'll make us irrelevant.
>> The final step to reach super
intelligence will happen when AI becomes
superhuman. Not only in coding, but in
AI research itself. They'll become
qualitatively better than the best human
researchers because they'll be able to
read every single machine learning paper
ever written, have been able to deeply
think about every single previous
experiment ever run at the lab, learn in
parallel from each of their copies, and
rapidly accumulate the equivalent of
millennia of experience. Jeffrey Hinton
is also worried that increasingly
powerful AI models could act as hive
minds, sharing what they learned with
each other, giving them a huge advantage
over humans. And here's why this is just
so dangerous for the human race. Humans
didn't out compete than Neanderthalss
because we were smarter. We were just
better at sharing knowledge culturally
and learning from the mistakes of other
humans. Now imagine millions of AIs all
thinking 100 times faster than humans
and instantly sharing new learnings with
each other. They'll speedrun a thousand
years of their own cultural evolution in
what feels to us like a single year.
Okay, but is this really the future
that's waiting for us or just a cool
sci-fi scenario? Let's take a look at
the limitations that could slow down the
intelligence explosion. So, this is a
series of questions every major AI lab
has been asking about how likely
recursive self-improvement is to lead to
fast takeoff and how the majority are
interpreting the evidence. One possible
bottleneck is limited compute. To make
algorithmic progress, AI researchers
have to run experiments and that takes
serious computing power. You simply
can't run machine learning experiments
if you don't have enough chips to run
them on. which is why the CEO of
Deepseek said that the American ban on
chips to China is their biggest problem.
But here's the thing. AI researchers
working at 100 times human speed are far
more likely to design more efficient
experiments in the same amount of time
compared to human researchers. So they
won't need to waste as much compute as
the inefficient humans. And as
algorithmic progress continues, those
same experiments also get cheaper and
more effective. Remember the cost to
achieve 50% on the math benchmark became
a thousand times cheaper in just a few
years. But maybe there are inherent
limits to algorithm progress. Maybe the
law of diminishing returns applies here
and there will be a point where
developing more intelligence will
eventually lead to smaller and smaller
increases in efficiency until we hit a
wall. But that seems pretty unlikely
because AI is still a young field and we
haven't thrown nearly as much of
humanity's brain power at it as we have
at other fields like math or physics.
For almost all of human history,
progress was flat. Then suddenly it
explodes. What does it feel like to
stand here? And the intelligence
explosion won't just stay in the lab.
Once we have super intelligence, it will
spill out into everything. factories
would go from humanrun to AIdirected
using human physical labor to soon being
fully run by swarms of robots. This
would massively accelerate scientific
progress. Imagine going from the Wright
brothers to fighter jets to the moon and
to ICBMs in just a few years. That's
just how Ashen Bunner sees the 2030s
going. An industrial and economic
explosion driven by an alien
intelligence.
Physical labor could be automated with
robot factories that cover the entire
Nevada desert. And all mental work could
be automated by data centers filled with
AI, all thinking faster than any human
ever could. We could see GDP growth
rates of 30% per year just by using
standard economists models of economic
growth. Yes, existing future red tape
would slow things down. For example,
governments could force lawyers and
doctors to be human by law. So the
intelligence explosion will likely be
very uneven. Some fields would grow
exponentially while others like the long
shoreman port workers where automation
can literally be made illegal would say
the same. But none of these changes
comes close to what super intelligence
means for military and governments.
Whoever controls super intelligence will
quite possibly have enough power to
overthrow the US government. Imagine
mosquito-sized drone swarms, novel WMDs,
things we can't yet fathom. Compared to
pre- super intelligence arsenals, it'll
be like 21st century militaries fighting
a 19th century brigades of horses and
bayonets. Even without robots, the small
civilization of super intelligences
would be able to hack any undefended
military, election, television, etc.,
and also cunningly persuade generals.
They could design new synthetic
bioweapons and then pay a human in
Bitcoin to synthesize them and so on. In
the early 1500s, Cortez and about 500
Spaniards conquered the Incan Empire of
10 million. They didn't have god-like
power, but the old world's technological
edge and an advantage in strategic and
diplomatic cunning led it to an utterly
decisive advantage. Super intelligence
might look similar. Super intelligence
is the ultimate game board flipper. Once
it arrives, it becomes almost impossible
to predict what will happen next.
There's a real possibility that we will
lose control as we are forced to hand
off trust to AI systems during this
rapid transition. The shift will be
fast, overwhelmingly fast. The world
won't have time to process what's
happening before everything starts to go
insane. Think about all the crazy things
that happened in the 20th century. Now
imagine all that compressed into just a
few years. Maybe this sounds like sci-fi
to you. It's not. Super intelligence is
the stated goal of the leading
scientists at the AI labs. And the heads
of the top three AI labs all think this
is likely coming in the next 2 to 5
years. Thousands of academics with no
financial stake in the AI industry,
signed a letter stating that AI poses a
risk of human extinction. Jeffrey
Hinton, who quit his high-paying job at
Google to warn the world, put our
chances of going extinct at 50%. The
intelligence explosion is an imminent
possibility, and we need to prepare for
now. If you want to see a detailed
concrete scenario of how this super
intelligence might take over, check out
this video next. This is a small
channel, and this video took a long time
to make. If you made it this far, thanks
for watching.